[Music]
bones ooh
welcome to markiplier makes arts fine
art the finest art that you have ever
seen that you will ever know have you
ever thought to yourself when you are
hard to believe on the summer's evening
and then you go and you see the Mona
Lisa I mean you know drifting in the
German and then you see the Mona Lisa
and it calls to you and you know that in
your blood you feel it in your heart a
little bit of yes that's what I'm sure
today we are going to make you the
finest art that you have ever seen
before in your life
but I cannot do too long no no no no no
I need my friends introducing
introducing Tyler the naked David statue
by a Leonardo da Vinci shied noticing
there with his tiny penis oh so small
but it was an artistic choice David
probably hung like horse but this time
law in this one very small you're
welcome and this time I would like to
introduce Ethan
Oh baguette eifel tower he has a
crippling disease he cannot stop
haunting husband cure it's a whole
miracle
alright anyway gotta kind of stuff going
to Scottish just got it you're a German
that entire time no talking what are you
talking to
so here is how it will go haha yes can
you smell the art in the air
well hi Amy your mum use your live
inspiration of all my art I said bones
you to you and then I feel it in my soul
do you not feel the same when you look
at me you do not feel the boss drawing
your maybe David over there with his
tiny penis Wow hahaha how many times
when you first came out here you say
small talk that doesn't this joke this
is also joke what you say you say this
is my room different in those centuries
in so really this is true I'm sorry is
something I am not admitting to anything
thinking I thank you we plan a great
what oh yeah I forgot I welcome back
ignore the technical difficulties that
we just saw today we are going to make
[Music]
no no that is wrong we are going to make
portraits buying friends oh we are going
to fight for the right through paint
each other and then when we paint each
other we will try to be at what what is
wrong it's accurate now it's to France
don't mind these [ __ ] care how work
we fight for right
to paint each other who people don't
know but maybe soon enough so when we
pick who who the other they pick each
other they need to be fine for we in
Rochambeau we do rock paper here
Rochambeau oh ah excellent choice you
know yeah you have to paint him a peg do
you print him yeah I can't paint must
know he paint me we have brow I paint
you yes he me mother that I paint you
we should get Pantene our futures oh
that works out much better didn't I
where's the black I have it in my hand
the fuchal take it eat dicks and sorry I
don't know where the end okay we have
our pens
and we have our amuses so now we paint
go who am i painting you can you paint
me oh [ __ ] boy mmm I've never painted
before in my life you've never painted
never not even finger paint no well
maybe I don't know we're poor children
growing up in the streets we didn't have
finger you had ha ha look at mr. rich
man here he had fingers growing fine you
know what art is about you know do you
know do you know what the definition of
art is if you if someone asks you hey
mr. encyclopedia
what's art what would you say to them
cuz I know the answer but I don't see if
you know who are you talking to I'm
talking to you oh I do but you know
let's compare notes after you say what
do you think art is well art is
something that you know is visual but it
comes from the inside not here but here
do your nose know anyway what you're
doing
I've Nadia it is a work in progress
well let's just leave it it's the full
motto which Leonardo da Vinci
you know bold the child who made the
Mona Lisa Leonardo DiCaprio that's it
use fermented I'd like to turn to the
brioche I wonder what the first color
was right in my mind right what was
first color black white what was the
first car that they recognized as color
is just a social construct it's true it
isn't made up in man how do you know my
blue isn't the same as your blue well
that's the thing is that our blues are
not the same even it's fine it's fine
fine Tyler don't look over here excuse
me don't look over here don't want to
knock over something like Ethan no I
don't look down I already saw it there
God keep doing that I keep scooping
paint and I forget that it's not digital
and it doesn't just don't weigh on your
brushes really you forgot that it's real
P I forgot I forgot how real Pig works
okay nothing my fault this [ __ ] thing
I've got to make some drastic changes
I think I'm just about done honestly
yeah all right I'll finish up soon then
you doing enough I think I'm done
Tyler how are you done it's not quite
how long not much longer we're gonna
each take turns doing a big review of
our amazing pieces of art and then we're
going to have them judged based on the
criteria of accuracy to the subject
overall artistic goodness and then which
one would the judges actually pay money
for okay oh it's done oh he's done and
now we will take turns revealing our art
and you will see oh you will see Charlie
do you want to go first cuz your art is
so fresh no I think it should be the
order of completion personally we will
do it Tyler first just because I want it
to piss him off don't worry about a
thing nothing a kind of odd but still
aren't all the same
I love the Clorox Wow
Zr here we have more outdoors on
vacation and this is what Mark would
look like if he actually took a vacation
he's wearing his own merch wearing
Wade's merch actually it's merch but
with a yes
so he's outdoors you can see chicas
running off to the side as Mark is
staring off into the distance with a
nice wispy day with release wisps dead
busy thinking about making videos mmm
even on vacation even on vacation I
never stopped are you ready for mine
oh it is our favorite Blueboy accurate
name delicious blueberry face cute you
want to pinch the cheeks isn't it me oh
ha ha and then your hair yes they
accurately your dreams and aspirations
yes for a demand play button oh and the
door at the beach cuz you move to LA I
love the beach hmm and you're a ghost
because you're dead oh just like my
channel well last but not least we have
talent no who looks like Bob if you take
a peek something happened here that is
there's a lot of there's a lot of
happenstance when she fell happen to get
there and I thought you know put your
face right up there put your face right
up there oh you cover me that's fine
perfect we have the toenail on there and
I just I couldn't dare to touch that
when when he baited smiles upon your
horse like that you got a smile back
yeah you got a smile I'm really curious
about your chin selection is my chin jut
out oh yeah mr. butt chin for me thank
you very much
you can't criticize yeah is accurate and
lips I thought we're very good and hair
obviously it's not like it is now but I
like the old Tyler yeah you've changed
you've changed we have our art gallery
here and we're ready to show it to the
judges so if we can have the judges come
down next
cool but relative my Mary's body size
it's not super thick
yeah so from my painting I went with
extreme realism like I went super real
hyper realism actually so the blue face
the acne which I wanted to kind of
understate because that's not really a
reflection of who he is um the the hair
just whenever I see it I'm pretty sure
this like oh no no I think that too but
it's actually his hair the overcast day
well no it's not very much it's not I
lied but lime is part of the experience
okay yeah what is what is real what do
you see how do you know the Ethan that I
see is in the even that you see this is
my representation of Tyler he's he's got
the big hair that he used to have real
that we all that we all get is that or
is that just I know I think that is
actual hair that might be mine and then
there is that is there's multiple real
hang-ups on this painting I wanted to
bring life into the painting and I did
that with real life elements like hair
and the toenail the toenail was really
something that wasn't planned at all it
just happened and I was like brilliant
brilliant brilliant brilliant brilliant
brilliant brilliant this is God's plan
the hair I tried to get swirly birds in
it
real swirly because Tyler's got curly
hair very curly hair a good texture yeah
and he's out in the rain
what rain because it's raining outside
in this depiction if that's the rain I'm
seeing it as more of a floating head
above a pond
I think it's accurate I think it's
sustained yes the state of life and age
it represents his timeline see when it's
bigger up here that's when he was a
child and so he had much more happiness
and like and you know he had these big
dreams and then as he aged they just
slowly thinned out until eventually
disappears no it's just raining because
they haven't been doing that not
incorrect he's not smiling incorrect
death of the artist okay he's not
smiling but that doesn't mean that he's
frowning it's a neutral pose listen you
can interpret it in any way that you
want but I'm saying to you that from the
artist himself that made the painting
he's not smiling but he's also not
frowning he's just there but as soon as
you've abandoned the work and open it up
to critique your interpretation he's not
just yours this is mine so you know the
tournelle looks like a tear he's crying
don't know well I think we'll hang it
over to the judges Thanks they are the
judges I will say mark took a lot of
creative and had a great imagination and
creating his and instead of just going
for realism he went for something just
different something that's that had to
have come from his mind instead of
something that he's just seen and
reimagined I think somehow Ethan
channeled his complete chaos inside of
him and put it on to the frame like it
wasn't you your hand here awful the
worst a child could do better okay but
your creative spirit falling down
toppling over everything
that's where it lies and that's where
you truly shine not here but right there
what I still think that looks way more
like Bob than me okay well this is 100%
you tablet final decisions from the
judges are you ready there are three
categories first one is accurate
accuracy which we are going to give art
the second one is just like good art
skill good technique exhibit it let me
give that to mark hey I did not think
that was gonna happen well actually no
you could clone your own Katherine from
that you could clone your own mystery
number of team apply wait what do you
what do you call that painting are you
gonna call it toenail come back to me I
call this one I'm blue buddy bad day
[Music]
mark stay with chica okay I think I'd
call this neutral feelings in the rain
that happens to be happening for no
apparent reason it's just the weather
for that day overall
absolutely my heart goes out to all of
you thank you for supporting me on this
endeavor I'd like to thank my mom and my
dad anyway tell us who you think should
win it won in the comments below so
thank you everybody so much for watching
Thank You judges for being here and
judging fairly if wrongly but fairly
yeah that's how we are here a team of
player HQ so thank you everybody so much
for watching get ready to not bid on
these because they're not going up for
auction they're gonna be hanging in our
office till the day we die the things
again everybody for watching and as
always we will see you in the next video
bye
[Music]